entre depuis la rivière du prêcheur
limpide il y a quelques jours a retrouvé
son aspect bull en plein milieu de la
nuit la sirène a réveillé la commune
habitant le voisinage à sortir se mettre
en sécurité
un choc après des bois de tranquillité
c'est énorme
et puis quand on est là on avait tous
les jeudis 28 cents tout tout tout le
temps comme ça non y'avait pas depuis
ils peuvent pas nous inquiéter beaucoup
alors serait ce cette année que ça
reprenne on m'a déjà dit c'est pas fini
pour l'observatoire de fond saint denis
les cumuls de pluies de ces derniers
jours ne permet pas d'expliquer ce
nouveau l'art l'on songe plutôt à la
rupture d'un grand bassin en amont suite
à l'effondrement d'une berge
si la situation n'inspire pas
d'inquiétude immédiate la saison des
pluies ne fait que commencer
avant ces sites c'est hélas on peut même
aller se rapprocher de la falaise mais
maintenant elle est tellement immenses
allaient devenir grand on voit que c'est
quelque chose qui va continuer et c'est
tout un flanc de la montagne pelée qui
équiperait disparaît tout ça moi aussi
un chantier coûte pour 1 pilotée par là
des halles va débuter pour plusieurs
mois
l'objectif affiché est de retirer 30 à
50 camions par jour de matériaux en
amont du pont jusqu'au gain l'état
décidé de mettre les bouchées doubles
parce que jusqu'à présent c'était la ctm
assez tm dont les compétences ou la
compétence sur le périmètre
d'intervention
la seule limite est donc a dit m avant
dix mètres après le pont je crois que
nous n'avions pas le choix il faut aller
vite il faut faire le nécessaire
sable et roches volcaniques les experts
estiment à 6 millions de mètres cubes
les matériaux à évacuer de la rivière du
prêcheur